it's a millionaire theme our we're
talking with Mike and he and his wife
are both in the military both engineers
a 1.2 million dollar net worth only 39
years old they make a hundred and eighty
between them and we didn't finish up
talking to him so what's the most
expensive jeans you ever bought Mike
probably 150 dollars but we we have we
hold on the clothes for a long time so
we've had him for quite a while before
you were a millionaire how many new cars
did you buy only one sir it was seven
years old we still have it today it's a
truck that I have and we're gonna keep
it for the foreseeable future as well
okay so tell me your story a little bit
because you've done this at a really
young age how did you get your income to
here get these degrees to here and not
have a policy and loan debt tell me what
happened here uh well sir both Heather
and I are graduates the United States
Military Academy and one of the reasons
I went to that school that was because
of the expense of education and my
parents weren't will not be able to send
me to college and pay for it and so
that's one of the things that drove to
bust you to choose less blunt as well
the fact we want to serve our country
and Heather had very humble background
she's from Oklahoma originally so you
know going to that institution allowed
us the opportunity to graduate and
obviously a debt to the nation we should
probably we should probably pay back and
have continued to serve throughout right
Wow okay so basically you joined the
military they pay for college and your
West Point grads is what you're saying
and in engineering that's no slouch at
all that's pretty strong so what did you
do to get your incomes up in the
military quickly is pretty regulated the
military the the biggest thing that we
did was just you know we had the
self-discipline like he's always say you
know behavior is 80% of solution to
really little off one salary so the
entire time we've been married we're
going really look up one income and we
have either vested or saved the second
income throughout the last 16 years that
we've been in the service Wow very
impressive
so deployment play a part in this
yes sir I've had five combat deployments
Afghanistan Iraq actually Heather's not
here with us today because she's
actually on her third deployment she's
actually in Kuwait this time so she's
down there right now she'll be back in
August oh my goodness wow you guys have
paid a price to get to this and you've
served your country fabulously in the
mean time so Wow
I'm so impressed you're very sharp young
couple I mean you're making serious
money 180s of no sloucher but hey a lot
of people can't seem to live on 90 and
you guys pulled that off of your bank in
the other 90 that's pretty neat yes sir
well congratulations man you are a great
American success story and thank you so
very much for serving your country and
please pass that along to your wife as
well very very cool story I think that's
our first military millionaire in the
millionaire themed hours we've done but
there you go just like that but West
Point graduates engineers big-time
officers I mean they're they're not you
know they're not entry-level they've
worked their tails off and they're
obviously both very sharp and they've
taken the deployments and those
deployments that's tax-free income
coming in man that's ding ding ding that
rings the bell a million two at 39 years
old
that's impressive hey you guys Rachel
Cruz here hope you are enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show if you didn't know I
actually have my own YouTube channel so
I had to do videos twice a week on life
and money so you can click the subscribe
button to subscribe to my channel and if
you want to check out our video right
now check out the video on how to make a
budget